- Yo, I’m kind of worried about the volcano.
Did you see how many Titans tested positive for lava?
- Ignore all that man. It's the freakin' QUARTER-SEASON CARNIVAL!
- Yo, what up I got a quick pass. Much love.
- WEEE!! I LOVE TO FEEL THE AIR THROUGH MY HAIR PUFF.
- Hey, guys, is this how you slide?
Cool! I keep winning by doing wacky s--t!
- Don't worry, loser still gets a prize.
- Whoa, I don't want that.
- I think I could do this with better coaching, but at this point, I’m not sure.
- I’m Danny Dimes, and I shoot like this!
- Step right up to the Tunnel of Jordan Love!
A ride that’s more scared of me than I am of it.
- So back when I was playing in Denver...wait, I was never on the Broncos.
How was I never on the Broncos?
- ♪♪♪ A starter goes above and beyond ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ to make sure there’s no greater bond. ♪♪♪
- BOOOOOOO.
- Oh Boooooo.
- [Carson, sighing].
- Yes, I fit. The bar is just too high. If you could lower the bar for me?
- [Announcer:] Do not fumble with the bar.
- CAN EVERYONE STOP QUESTIONING MY DECISION-MAK—